[Music]
all right and next up we have dr
sadika watson
so perhaps as i get set up here i can
add to my resume that
max opened for me so
now i'm kind of a big deal i guess
all right
okay so um
good afternoon so my name is sadika
watson
i am a senior data scientist at a
consulting firm called
illicit insights most of our projects at
illicit are
in the customer analytics and employee
analytics space
and i'd be happy to chat more about some
of those projects after this session
but this presentation is about a fun
little side project that i've been
working on so
i've listed my speaker affiliation here
coralosi data insights
so title neural networks for
longitudinal data analysis
first let's start with the definition so
longitudinal data
are recorded on the same units at
multiple points in time
and so as an example you could think
about a clinical trial where
you might have a patient observed over
multiple time points maybe every
three months every six months or
something they come in and you take
their vital signs
you weigh them you take blood or tissue
samples and then maybe you record some
biomarkers at each of the different time
points
so that's a healthcare example another
example could come from retail where
maybe you'd observe a customer's
behaviors or characteristics
every month or perhaps you're analyzing
user behavior so maybe you're at
facebook or twitter
and um you're looking at how the users
behave or interact with the platform
every day
so there are lots of other examples
in those applications we're looking at
people
over time but we could also have a
longitudinal data set that stores
information about buildings or objects
pets anything really whatever it is
again we're looking at the same thing
over multiple time points
and they don't have to be but the
usually the time points are evenly
spaced so
say we're making observations every day
or every month
and then the units don't necessarily
have to have the same number of
observations so thinking back to that
clinical trial example
some patients might come in only twice
and then some patients might come in 10
times
and you can think of each unit as having
a matrix of data where
the variables are observed or across the
top of the matrix and the time points
are in the
rows sean layman
has a baseball database that is a
fantastic example of longitudinal
data collection his data set has
information about players in various
roles and positions going back to about
1871
and these data are available in the r
package called layman
so when you install the package you'll
automatically get access to all those
data sets
but you could also visit his website and
download those as csvs
from his website and when we load the
tables we get information about how well
the players performed
how well their teams performed as a
group whether they won any awards
whether they switched teams
all sorts of great information about the
players and for baseball hitters
in particular the batting statistics
table captures
all of the usual performance metrics
that are commonly reported on
how well they were hitting in particular
there are three
primary baseball outcomes that make up
what's called the slash line
and these include the batting average
the on base percentage and the slugging
percentage
and these are usually reported as
decimal numbers that are rounded to
three decimal places with slashes
in between them in that particular order
so let's suppose that we are
particularly interested in three
baseball players and we know a lot of
information about them over the past
three seasons
but we like to know or predict how
they're going to perform
in the following season so can we do
that
the first player in our collection of
three players is
willie mays and again we're just a spitz
throw away from black history month so i
wanted to make sure i highlighted a
a high performing african-american
player
so willie mays he had this incredible
season in 1965
and in his slash line both his on-base
percentage and his lugging percentage
led the league so he's just this
powerhouse of a player right in
particular 1965 was a good year for him
the second player is greg nettles he uh
in 1986 was playing his 20th
season um as a 41 year old which is
really old
for uh for a player for a non-pitching
uh
or non-pitching player i'm almost 40 so
you know it's very young for other
situations
and so his performance in 1986 was okay
right so he's an example of a moderate
player and then we finally have
uh chris davis uh who had a
terrible season in 2018 i'm sure maybe
some of the baseball fans probably know
a lot about him
he signed this massive 161 million
dollar contract and has been just
vastly unperforming underperforming that
um
and so uh in that year in particular
like i said was a terrible year so
uh so the question is now that we have
these three players in mind
um with varying performance with their
actual slash lines
shown below we like to somehow build a
model that can predict these outcomes
now for this type of scenario we have
three
key modeling considerations first we
know that there is a very strong
correlation between past
performance and future performance so
data from one year
to the next are highly correlated and so
we should have some sort of smart way to
encourage
encode these these temporal dependencies
and exploit them
if possible next we'd like to avoid
max left right we like to avoid
feature engineering over the different
time periods
and so if you may have been dealing with
this type of scenario in the past maybe
if you had
data over multiple time points you might
say okay let me aggregate somehow over
the different time points
how many runs they had or look at some
percentage from one period to the next
or something like that
and then we might also have to manually
encode some of the interactions between
some of the variables
obviously we're limited by time and our
own imaginations right so there's almost
an infinite number of ways that you
could do that
and so we'd like to if possible allow
the algorithm to
come up with those types of
transformations
and then finally we would like this
model to
flexibly accommodate different types of
model outputs
we might want to predict more than one
outcome at a time
so such as in our example where we want
to predict the three numbers in the
slash line
and normally in a regression you would
have three separate models right where
you individually predict those three
those three outcomes and then so each of
those individual models
are learning separate patterns that are
predictive of each of those outcomes but
maybe you want to have one model
maybe it's easier to maintain that looks
at individual
patterns that can come together and
simultaneously predict all of those
outcomes
and maybe we also want to think about
predicting over multiple time points so
maybe saying for those three players
could we predict how they performed over
the next two or three seasons
right so that's a lot to ask
is there a modeling framework that can
do all of that
okay so recurrent neural network models
to the rescue
um those um for people who have seen
those before
you may have been aware that those
naturally accommodate temporal
dependencies you've probably seen them
before in
different types of sequential data
analyses such as written text or
audio there are some variants such as
long short short-term memory and gated
recurrent units
that can regulate the flow of
information through the network from
in particular looking at data from one
period to the next so this slide
shows an example of how information
would flow
through such a network for our
incredible season 1965 season for our
high performing player willie mays
and we see that he has the same
attributes age
games number of hits number of runs etc
recorded um at uh with different values
for each of these uh
years in 1962 1963 and 1964.
and so the model is learning all of
these season to season
patterns overall the players that are
predictive of these
three outcomes in the slash line
to prepare the data we must break each
player's record into these four these
rolling four season windows
and so what that includes is the three
seasons remember that we're using for
prediction those so those will be the
input years
of data and then we've got the one
season in the future right
so one of the things that was an issue
of course because players are not
active every single year is that if they
were inactive for a particular season we
have to do some padding and so there are
some utilities in our that were helpful
for that
we have to pad the series to accommodate
the skipped years
but for example for willie mays we could
think about
predicting 1962 so we're using the data
from 59
60 and 61 and using that to predict his
62
performance and he was also active in 63
so we can slide that window to the right
and have 60 60 and 62
predicting 63 and we can do it again to
predict 64
and slide it over one more time to
predict 65 now this of course means that
our data samples are not independent
and this is okay for now because we're
focusing primarily on the predictions
that we're getting from
the model at the moment but there are
some other aspects of this model where
we will have to address this
dependence issue head on and so i'll
revisit that a little later in the talk
i focused on data collected between 1916
and 2018 and i only looked at the
player's first stent so i didn't
consider what happened after they were
traded to another team and this was
really just
more of because of the way that the data
was collected it was actually
reporting performance on each individual
stent i could have also aggregated
across the different time points if i
was doing this for real but again this
was just an illustration
i only looked at players that had at
least four consecutive seasons
and think about the way that i'm
constructing these rolling windows
so a player that has a longer career has
more rolling windows right i'm sliding
that window over a longer period of time
so
that player will have more points in the
data set
so to limit their influence i
downsampled players that had longer
careers
and then to focus on hitters i required
the player to have at least 85
plate appearances now
another issue is that so we also want to
avoid
data leakage and so think about the fact
that we randomly are splitting the data
into training and testing and validation
sets
it's possible to have the same player
represented in training and testing and
validation if we're not careful right
and so
in order to avoid that one thing we
could do is to just randomly split on
the players
so you have the training players the
validation players
testing players and then you can compute
the rolling windows for those individual
players
across the data splits as a benchmark
i fit an ordinary least squares
regression model where the seasons the
three
the three seasons of player data are
represented in y
format so if we had 100 features that
means we've got 300 columns of data
and for 1.100 for each time period i
didn't do any manual feature engineering
remember that was one of the things i
said in the beginning that i was trying
to avoid
and i just used the data as it was aside
from
doing some normalization to the zero one
scale for the
attributes and features and i did that
for the neural network approach as well
for the neural network approach i tried
different models that included
one or more gated recurrent unit layers
and then one or more fully connected
dense layers
with tons of hyperparameter values tuned
over the grid
and then i represented the model in two
ways
the first approach was to look at three
single outcome
models where each model was just
predicting a single
metric in the slash line and then i also
looked at a multi-outcome model where
i'm simultaneously predicting all three
metrics
it isn't on the slide again but i
mentioned that um normalization to the
zero one scale
and so max's talk just before this one
was timely
again just thinking about model tuning
and how important that is
in machine learning and neural networks
in particular so
you're probably aware that these models
involve a lot of parameters that must be
tuned
and a single run of this kind of model
can take
you know many minutes or hours or days
sometimes
and so to cut down on the computational
time i use
free services from google collab they
allow to use a gpu
for free within reason obviously i think
they put some limits of up to 12 hours
of
of modeling but that was completely free
so that was helpful here
especially for projects where you're
just kind of playing around with
something obviously you'd want to
probably use something like aws
you know the gpu if you're working on a
real project
my github repository has a complete
minimal example
showing how you could potentially
implement this type of model in r
um the version that i'm showing doesn't
include all of the data joins and
filtering and
data transformations that were specific
to the the baseball example
so if you run this you won't see the
results that i'm going to share on the
next few slides
but i did it this way because i wanted
to keep this example simple enough so
that
you could think of this as a template
that you could modify
for your purposes as and use it as
inspiration for
your projects okay so after all of that
how did we do right in our three
modeling approaches the first graph
that i'm going to show here shows the
performance in the ordinary least
squares regression model
on our held out test set and so for each
outcome and the slash line i'm plotting
the predicted values against the actual
values
and this dashed line is a reference that
shows where the actuals match the
predicted
which is where we want a majority of our
points to lie in a great prediction
model
and as you can see this is not a great
prediction model
right it's terrible okay
and our three selected players
performances are shown in the colored
stars i don't know if you can see those
but
i i chose red for terrible yellow for
moderate and green for great
um so again it doesn't seem to be doing
a good job of predicting the outcomes
for any of them
next we see the performance of the best
gradient boosted machine
regression models that we observed over
the grid of hyperparameter values
and you might have noticed from this
slide compared to the previous one that
the mean square error
is lower but it doesn't appear to be
doing a much better
job of predicting compared to even
ordinarily squares and
so i have a couple theories about that
one is that we
again there's the data from time point
one time point two time point three
where it's not actually clear
to the data um to the to the model that
there's some temporal dependency here so
that's actually not being captured there
so that's one thing and the second is
that there might be some types of data
transformations or
you know interactions or something that
where if if we were to manually encode
some of those things
maybe the model might might be better
okay and then finally we have our neural
network model fits
and notice how a majority of the points
lie close to the line
often on the line and for our three
selected players the model was able to
capture
willie may's excellent performance greg
nettle's
okay performance and chris davis's
terrible performance in those three
specific years
so yeah i can quit my job and work in
fantasy
baseball and make a lot of money right
so obviously this was done more for
illustration purposes if i was really
trying to deploy this of course i'd have
to you know do a lot of other types of
validation
um but again this is illustrating the
the point that
these types of models are useful for
longitudinal data analysis
there are some issues that i haven't
talked about in this short talk that we
might explore in a future session
i mentioned earlier that the neural
network
enables you to predict multiple time
steps in the future but i haven't
talked about how you would do that
really that it just involves changing
the shape of the output layer
and so that's just making some you also
have to make some adjustments to the
loss function potentially if you were
wanting to for example
emphasize that you want the model to
perform better in
earlier time points compared to later
time points or later versus earlier or
something like that so those are those
are things that you could do
and then the elephant in the room again
is that i have not talked about
prediction intervals so we talked about
point estimates estimating that one
number
but getting some sort of estimate of
some range of values some reasonable
range of values that that actual value
could lie
within is something that we would have
to
spend a little bit more time thinking
about remember we were talking about
that correlation structure
from before there's this nagging
dependence issue where we've that we've
introduced by
producing these rolling windows so
that's something we would certainly have
to work out
and then here are the reference links to
the sean layman
baseball data sets that i referenced
earlier and i also give you the link to
my github repo
where the slides and the code are
available thank you
[Applause]
all right we have time for a few
questions um first one is
what packages did you use to train your
models
wow great and i actually just deleted
that slide um so
the ordinary least squares regression
model was just based on the
um the stats package i fit the gbms
using h2o
and then the neural network models were
fit using tensorflow and keras packages
and all this was done in r of course
all right and then how do you deal with
cases where certain players may have
more or less past observations
for example predicting one player in his
12th season and another in his third
so the length of the season remember we
intentionally
used that common length of time
of window remember where we had
the task was to predict using the
players previous three seasons
with their next performance was going to
be in the following season so in that
sense it really didn't matter how long
they had
played overall it was a sense of how can
we actually
translate that data structure into the
one that the model is actually going to
represent that represents this
particular modeling task
but that is actually a really good
question because as i'm sure if you work
with
lstms and these kinds of models they are
they can accommodate various lengths
right so you could potentially say
given the players entire history given a
player that has played whether they
played two years or 10 years or however
long they've played
what is their last season going to be
right
and it is very easy to do that you don't
necessarily have to specify ahead of
time
or lock in a particular length of season
so that's that's fairly easy to do
and yeah i don't have time to go into
that solution but it is very
straightforward to do
all right one more question what are
some diagnostic plots
sanity checks you can use to see if your
rnn is behaving
properly sure great question i didn't
really
go into it as much but i flashed up on
the screen let's see if i can go back to
it
so the example that i provided on my
github page
does provide some two piece two types of
graphs one is just the
individual loss function losses for the
individual outcomes
so that's for each of the different
outcomes in the slash line individually
and then there's this overall loss
function so you could actually see
how those lines are behaving whether or
not we're actually getting convergence
whether or not we're actually continuing
to see training beyond a certain number
of iterations
and then also just as a means of
monitoring
in intuitive terms how well the model's
doing
on the right side i'm also just showing
that predicted versus actual plot
as well but yeah there's a ton of other
things that you could
that you could do perfect thank you so
much
and next up we have nick strayer
you